day 62 intentions are running sky high
on the set of love and thunder because
this mood is an all-time low i'm about
to go and help pick up the spirits with
my bubbly energetic personality
this is ten years for me
i'd have loved every time i played the
character this new film transitions us
from end game into a rebirth for doesn't
know what his place is in the universe
that's represented in his wardrobe as
well
i was really excited to come back as the
mighty thor and get to share the mantle
i love it to have both of us in
the same cape
um that was amazing and incredible
especially with tyka at the helm tiger
he's like a big kid he's like a sort of
a genius child i wasn't afraid to be
flamboyant and a bit camp
three two one
giant goats look at those they are
wonderful yes they are they also scream
quite a lot it's hugely imaginative and
fun like such an enormous scale
it's a crazy space adventure with a new
villain he's pretty monstrous
oh god she won't die
we really raised the bar with ragnarok
love and thunder is even more unique and
different so it's pretty exciting
[Music]
[Music]
you